[Música]
a gente vive essa hype de uma sopa de
letrinhas em inglês
aí o tyloo machine inteligência
artificial e eu quero compartilhar com
vocês algumas coisas mas é capaz a lusa
agora e o alarme de incêndio tocar e eu
tivesse que deixar uma última bala seria
que o de uma maneira de criar meus
filhos
pelo que eu aprendi nessa cultura de
startup é modelo de formação a falência
das formas com essa trilha normal do
certificado
muitas vezes não leva ao sucesso há
consequências e dizer que é tecnologia
muitas vezes nesse processo de
transformação digital é commodity ea
gente tem que trabalhar muito mais os
nossos comportamentos ea maneira como a
gente ficar o nosso percurso do que
necessariamente ter essa ansiedade de
adquirir conhecimentos que talvez a
gente nem tenha né
e eu queria convidar vocês a alguns
passos atrás talvez 23 em relação à
expectativa de ver muita coisa em
relação a essa chamada transformação
digital
mas a gente fazia um processo interno de
entender e reconhecer que a gente vive
uma era tia certo né
o excesso de passado gerando depressão
o excesso de presente gerando estresse
excesso de futuro gerando ansiedade em
excesso de desejos e expectativas
gerando prestações
eu digo e repito de mudar a maneira de
criar o thiago que tem 10 anos e daniel
que tem oito
entendendo que tem algumas nuances e
algumas atitudes que a gente tem que
mudar em relação a esse mundo em
transformação e essa palavra ela tem
crescido muito a palavra
rosa porque a gente não foi informado
pra sonhar né se é a gente faz 17 anos o
mundo pára de girar e um cachorro
a tia a mãe o pai a família só tem uma
pergunta pra nós que vestibular você vai
fazer e como se isso fosse a coisa mais
importante do mundo ea gente não sei se
vocês lembram a gente apartado advogado
quando a gente tem 16 17 anos entre
exatas biológicas e humanas ea gente
nunca parou para perceber se a gente
teve uma péssima professora de
matemática
muitas vezes a gente se refugia na
história você a gente teve uma péssima
professora de geografia a gente pode se
refugiar na física ou na tecnologia e
esse é o primeiro erro da nossa formação
no mundo que exige competências
multidisciplinares
a gente começa a ser formado de uma
maneira um indisciplinado e pior como é
gente como a gente é adolescente
a gente passa formando a nossa
identidade funcional e olhando para o
futuro a acreditar que a nossa
identidade
tem a ver com o nome de um curso
superior
e esse é o começo de grandes problemas
porque os nossos pais nos ensinaram a
sonhar
nosso pai nossa mãe não chegou para nós
naquela época e perguntou assim meu
filho que você sonha que você curte
que impacto você quer fechar nessa vida
mas sim uma preocupação gigante que a
gente fizesse uma boa faculdade formasse
conseguir um bom emprego que não vai
existir mais comprar um carro um
apartamento
então nesse mundo em transformação quem
não tem na essência aquilo que a rota e
sonha querendo fazer muito falar um
pouco pra vocês sobre isso realmente vai
ter muita dificuldade de sobreviver
e é a grande questão fazendo aqui uma
pergunta pra vocês é a imagem mais
antiga desse slide as telefonistas
computadoras que precisavam conectar a
nossa voz com vio para que a ligação se
completasse ou lançamento desse primeiro
produto é claro que todos nós vamos
responder rapidamente que a imagem mais
antiga é a imagem em preto e branco 0 e
é claro que todos nós estão errados
porque essa imagem gastou 60 anos para
ficar velho
quem quer ver a primeira versão daquele
produto para ser lançado
levanta a mão a grande mensagem aqui é
entender que o ciclo da mudança mudou e
ele agora é muito rápido e talvez quando
a gente acorde e se olha no espelho a
gente enxerga uma pessoa que a gente
pressupõe mais moderna mais
contemporânea mais politicamente correta
a gente tem muito rica dificuldade de se
colocar em perspectiva e entender que a
cada dia a gente fica um pouco mais
centralizado
é mais ou menos como se eu perguntasse a
vocês quem quer aprender a jogar só 31
10 11 12 13 anos pudesse levantar a mão
e um grupo e cantavam com orgulho
gigante por entender que tinha uma
vantagem competitiva de um pensamento
estratégico
mas a verdade agora a gente tem que
aprender a regra nova de um jogo
toda semana então bom aquilo que a gente
aprendeu daquilo que eu me formei ele
não existe mais e isso tem a ver com o
nosso cognitivo
a gente nunca leu tanto e nunca leu tão
superficialmente por que a gente faça
dela a gente avança mas a gente retém
cada vez menos e por isso se você não
tiver propósito e uma clareza muito
grande
o foco daquilo que você pedir tudo
aquilo que te move e cada uma tem um
sonho
você não vai chegar a lugar nenhum
existe uma grande universidade americana
tem
o empreendedorismo duas vezes por ano
ela vai à áfrica e ela só existe um
campo de futebol e ela junta jovens
adolescentes e pergunta o que ele sonho
e uma menina depois de vários levantarem
a mão dizendo eu quero ser atriz
eu quero ser jogador de futebol ela
disse eu quero acabar com o lixo no
lugar onde eu moro
porque as pessoas não têm a educação
formação e ela joga o lixo no chão com
as necessidades ea melhor universidade
de empreendedorismo do mundo ensinou
essa menina a mobilizar desde recursos
de pessoas para realizar o sonho delas
então a gente também tem que dar um
passo atrás entender que cada um sonha
com aquilo que as vidas de maneira
diferente nem dons de um sonho restrito
até um apartamento melhor ou a comprar
um carro e é isso que move as pessoas no
lugar de transformação nesse mundo onde
tudo é rápido né
e a gente tem uma dificuldade absurda de
se colocar em perspectiva
porque se eu pegar e cilindro e eu
pudesse projetar ele é e no meio desse
espaço onde a gente está perdendo do
olhar ou da luz onde eu lanço a minha
visão a bola é um quadrado ou a forma um
círculo
o objeto é verdade mas a sua projeção
dependendo do ângulo que estou também é
verdadeiro e nós temos uma dificuldade
imensa por ausência de informação dessa
competência de nos colocar sempre e
perspectiva porque as pessoas não querem
inovar as empresas não querem inovar
porque isso biologicamente é avesso a
formação da nossa espécie
nós somos formados para buscar segurança
previsibilidade e planejamento no mundo
que cada vez menos permite que a gente
tenha cada um quadro cada uma dessas
três características então se do
planejamento é cada vez mais curto
também essa imagem fala de uma
experiência e uma fundação americana de
educação onde um cientista incrível fez
uma palestra sobre empreendedorismo
ciclo da idéia da operação
depois ele contou o caso desta pessoa
que está a imagem é o químico ele era
neto de escravos no sul-americano mais
racista na década de 50 ele não era
filha de empresários e aqui estou
falando de atitude propósito ele impera
até de escravos era uma pessoa muito
pobre e ele como autodidata desenvolveu
um mecanismo para construir uma fábrica
de gelo e rapidamente se tornou um
negócio de ouro e ele teve que contratar
uma pessoa de cor branca para fingir que
era o dono da fábrica para que ele
pudesse ser bem sucedido ea história
dele se tornou um livro de referência
nos estados unidos
mas a frase do quebre esse amigo dos
estados unidos disse o seguinte entendam
que empreender não é abrir um negócio
não é abrir um cnpj mas é permitir que
pessoas comuns passam coisas
extraordinárias
o mundo tem muitas pessoas
extraordinárias assistem zuckerberg eo
nos tantos mas eles se movem em
velocidade e muito maior intensidade por
pessoas comuns que todos os dias
perceberam fazendo coisas
extraordinárias o contrário da
idealização que a gente faz de uma
competência extrema de uma genialidade
mundial que a gente não tem
empreender permitir empodera pessoas
comuns a fazerem coisas extraordinárias
e vocês que estão aqui nessa cidade
incrível tem que entender isso a
importância de uma comunidade com um
propósito para o crescimento exponencial
dessa cidade
a ação individual de cada um eo
propósito individual se restringir ao
como crescer e ganhar mais dinheiro não
vai fazer desse lugar lugares
potencialmente melhor
a soma de vontades individuais nunca
será maior que a soma de duas por
pessoas com propósito extraordinário
algumas delas até aqui reunidas
organizando esse evento incrível
a bolsa do propósito da garra e da
vontade pessoas do propósito se reúnem
para resolver o problema do mundo desde
1911 em vários lugares
essa conferência ela reúne algumas
pessoas insignificantes a linguagem em
pó
o iceberg vieram prêmios nobel se
reuniam simplesmente como aqui a
organização do tênis para promover o
conhecimento ea busca de soluções isso
não é algo novo na história da
humanidade já estava no escritório e foi
convidado para conhecer um centro de
inovação e uma fração de segundo o bc
esse erro que eu vou colocar essa mala e
aí falaram que ele reconhecer israel e
quando eu ficar em israel o dia tinha
que ter novos apetrechos porque israel é
um estado menor porque sergipe
cercado de inimigos com 70% de seu
território deserto e de repente quando
eu estava em choque a ocupação
eu vi essa imagem com essa imagem que
tirar foto com meu celular é o sorvete
lote dela vida em 1909
eu acho que esses carros completando
assim a operadora tem direito pela dona
da esquerda
eu não via nada assim construir e hoje
israel é o menor do estado de sergipe
produtos mais importados do japão china
índia coreia do sul e reino unido
somadas será de dna do povo e trio é
mais desenvolvido no todo o povo
brasileiro
o ataque um propósito claro não tirar
transformação hoje israel concentra a
maior quantidade de 171 o mundo
ora os estados unidos a proposta
novamente quando não existe distância e
paixão e obrigação dentro de você você
se levanta e acorda pra fazer algo que
concentra adianta muito
é isso que faz israel sei o que é porque
eles vivem por propósito ele não vir por
acidente né ii caminhando para o fim eu
queria compartilhar nessa história
enredo doar a área é escrever um livro
famoso e ele conta que em algum momento
da história da humanidade é uma uma
carta como o ambiental de dois filhotes
de macacos era um é apertar o outro
seria os sacos e tomou alguma razão de
ouro tecnológico tendo uma diferenciação
e ele conta essa experiência feita com
macacos de onde os cientistas foram ao
habitats das florestas em gravaram os
riscos dos animais vão gravar um bom
ataque do leão o ataque de água e depois
recolheram esses animais para o
laboratório simulando uma floresta
tornar um player que o som e quando a
via é a parte de área
os macacos de silvas árvores quando
haviam a parte de leão o sol ele sobre
um casal novo quer de comunicação mas
nenhum dos animais da espécie humana é
capaz de dizer o seguinte se apresentar
ao seu grupo e falar assim
eu estava há cinco montanhas atrás o
término da copa do rio e vi um bando de
leões e se aproximando de nós essa
habilidade singular
ela é restrita a espécie humana nós
somos a única espécie do mundo que é
capaz de imaginar o que é capaz de
descrever
a gente não vê portanto que é capaz de
sonhar e foi essa habilidade que nos
permitiu desenvolver a arquitetura
conseguir falar dominar o mundo fazendo
bem fazer o mal
portanto a chave da sobrevivência na era
pós digital é a criatividade e o
propósito é a sua essência daquilo que
nos formou e que nos permite ser melhor
caso falar essa frase o problema dos
computadores é que eles só sabem dar
respostas não sabe fazer bem e esse
desafio que cada um de nós quer resolver
a entender que a gente tava mundo
intensa transformação né
é ela disse pra vocês vão de madeiras
grave os filhos e depois de algumas
dessas muitas viagens para esses temas
inovadores universidades israel no vale
do silício
eu vou ter um dia entendendo que o
processo de aprendizagem correr por ele
é o mais importante eo meu filho daniel
me fez aprender uma coisa muito
interessante
aí os dois do produto vai de sempre
deste evento da cultura do estado porque
a colaboração é um espírito de pessoas
querendo transformar mas o dano um dia
no café da manhã a água chega antes da
viagem ele falou assim eu tenho vontade
de andar de skate mas eu caio muito
eu falei meu filho e com que você roubar
a 10 para aprender se tem que cair tem
machucar
tem que sair sangue e você se
reequilibrar de novo e de repente
entendeu com pessoas chorar assim mais
um bom eu não gosto de e aí o link logo
15 anos de idade
a gente já tem medo de errar vocês já
pararam para perceber que a gente não é
criado para aprender mas para evitar o
erro
a gente evita se posicionar a gente tem
medo de fazer colocações
o medo de errar e o dano então foi
ataque skate na praça onde o capacete
não atrapalha de equilíbrio dele e o
dado caiu e cada um de nós um lugar do
dano nesse exato momento tarde olhando
pra ver quem viu que a gente caiu
enfim o que a gente errou e essa é a
etapa do nosso comportamento só cantando
tinha lavagem cerebral do pai e ele
perdeu de novo sem medo de errar
dessa vez no entanto conseguiu a mesma
maneira tiago quando com seis anos iria
tocar guitarra até hoje prendeu uma está
apresentando o violão
falaram que não podia então no principal
desafio é falar com os meus filhos não
podem nunca breve nenhum momento o
vestibular eles vão fazer
mas eu quero popular a cada dia através
da convivência e da inspiração a vontade
de encontrar um sonho e algo muito
grandioso que licitou e que faça a
diferença porque a partir daí eles vão
buscar a informação eo conhecimento que
eles precisam para realizar o sonho
deles você tem que cobrar essa ampla e
não fazer a sua compreensão do passado o
tempo em que aprender tecnologia talvez
fosse difícil
o filtro do seu olhar sobre o futuro eo
futuro já chegou a hora de voar só
depende de vocês e desejo a cada um
o propósito é incrível para viver uma
vida de transformação
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]